[Music]
on this saturday night worries over
weather in the west
ybc is battling a wildfire season that's
ramping up at a time when it usually
dies down our weather modeling is saying
that
our fire season will continue until at
least mid-september as hot dry
conditions kill crops across alberta
canola harvests of the future i do see
this as being
provide some long-term stability for
farmers how farmers are growing more
heat tolerant varieties but will it be
enough to meet market needs
support the stranded the u.s government
pushes airlines to help travelers or
face new rules
plus carving a new future it helps you
get through your days and stuff here
we're all trying to rehabilitate the
totem pole project helping vancouver
island inmates build community in prison
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight nithu ganja good
evening and thanks for joining us across
canada many forested and grassland
regions have been dealing with wildfires
as extreme heat and dry conditions
impact much of the country in british
columbia new fires are popping up daily
officials say the current conditions
combined with a highly charged weather
forecast are cause for concern kamal
kermali has our top story tonight
as the wildfire fight continues across
bc crews face an ongoing threat not from
the ground but from above to the
lightning we've seen in the last couple
of days
because we did see an increase there
were more than 11 000 lightning strikes
in the past 48 hours in bc out of more
than a hundred new fires started in the
province over the last two days nearly
three-quarters of them were caused by
lightning extending the province's
wildfire season usually winding down
this time of year now in a rare
occurrence it's expected to go on until
late september within the last five
years we've definitely seen
warmer drier conditions and so our fire
seasons have been longer than they had
been you know previous to that and
that's thanks you know to
overall weather
changing what doesn't help is a
lightning charged forecast we do have
the ingredients no relief we're also
tracking lightning this will cause a big
concern for the remaining of summer and
into early fall wildfires continuing to
plague the rest of the country the fire
danger index at high or extreme in many
parts of western canada including
alberta where wildfires have already
burned doubled the area they did last
year the last couple of weeks have been
very hot in the province here in alberta
we haven't seen much rain uh the
wildfire danger will escalate it's up to
extreme in a lot of different places
across the province over in saskatchewan
there have been more than
345 wildfires this year surpassing the
five-year average of 332.
parts of bc have implemented a fire ban
no open fires no briquettes and so it's
just
propane barbecues at this time and
although that might slow down the number
of human-caused fires all eyes will be
on how much damage mother nature ignites
next week kamal karamali global news
vancouver
this heat wave and lack of rain is
killing crops and farmland across parts
of alberta as jill krotel reports the
stress on ranchers and farmers desperate
for rain is taking its toll
we need inches of rain the pasture is so
parched in parts of the province
ranchers and farmers say it would take a
miracle from mother nature for some of
their acres to recover if you don't have
nerves of steel don't go into
farming luckily for us i have three
businesses off the farm and my wife is
full-time employed
but if i depended on this as an income
you couldn't make it at all
their cows and calves on this ranch near
black diamond have nothing to feed on
and may not survive we're now having to
look at okay now you just have to you
know call the crop and take them to the
auction and kill them off because
there's such a drought here that no
other farmers are going to the auction
to buy mike house i have to choose to
take my cattle to auction early and sell
them at a loss or lower price
or pay for more feed and then still lose
money
leroy newman grows wheat barley canola
and peas near blocky crops were hurting
from it so this year we we're probably
going to have an average crop but
it was going to be a bumper crop because
we had seven inches of rain in june and
then we only then it shut right off in
july and we got an inch and a half
the unpredictability and reliance on
rain is draining you learn to grow with
it like this is farming a lot of people
are in in hard times right now mentally
because some of the guys in eastern
alberta are they're in the third year of
a drought and he says he's running the
combines off their regular schedule
because in these heat waves there's a
higher risk of sparks from equipment
triggering a fire in the tender dry
fields
jill crotell
news
it is often called canada's cinderella
crop and now the market for canola is
growing yet again new clean fuel
regulations are putting a home-grown
climate solution on the map but as sarah
often reports whether or not the
industry will be able to meet the demand
remains in question
ian chitwood is looking at a bumper
canola crop this fall we can get an
early harvest
fantastic it's a good thing not only
have producers seen record high canola
prices this year they're also preparing
to spread their seed
to a new market this is a really good
home growing solution that
fuel producers have so it's a win-win
for everyone as part of the clean fuel
regulations released by the federal
government earlier this summer fuel
distributors are required to reduce
emissions 15 percent by 2030. one of the
ways they can do that is by diluting
petroleum with a lower carbon
substitute enter canola crops which
under the new regulations have finally
made the cut we've been working with
them over the past number of years to
include
canola specifically as a biofuel
feedstock
and with the new regulations
the cfr recognizes canola as a
low carbon intensity
biofuel feedstock but questions are
being raised about the overall impact
the changes will have on curbing
emissions one that will depend on
whether farmers can rain in emissions
during the process of seeding
fertilizing harvesting and transport if
done poorly with poor practices you can
have biofuels pathways that are as high
in greenhouse gas emissions as a
petroleum-based product
all the way through to pathways that do
it really well and actually
have a net negative effect on the
environment for consumers some suggest
the addition of more biofuel in the mix
could also reduce fuel efficiency and
continue to drive up costs both of food
and fuel i expect between 2024 and 2030
an average increase of anywhere between
three and four cents a liter and that's
over and above the government's current
increase of three to four cents a liter
on its carbon taxes canola just one of
the crops that will supply a number of
new major renewable diesel refineries
including a 20 000 barrel a day facility
near edmonton opening in 2024 yet more
proof demand is about to search for this
already hot commodity
sarah often global news calgary
in southern china farmers are struggling
to save crops threatened by
unprecedented drought the countryside is
tinder dry with a heat wave that's
lasted more than two months on friday
state media reported temperatures
reached 45 degrees in some regions water
is being redirected from canals and
streams into the cracked fields to
irrigate crops since june the country
has been grappling with extreme weather
from heat waves to historic floods in
northern china rescue teams are trying
to evacuate some people who've been
trapped in their homes after heavy
rainfall
the united nations says it's working
with western countries to get russian
food and fertilizers to global markets
in order to avoid a global food crisis
without fertilizer in 2022
there may not be enough food in 2023
getting more food and fertilizer out of
ukraine and russia is critical
to further count commodity markets and
lower prices for consumers
the un secretary general says russia's
war in ukraine has created major
obstacles for the shipment of russian
food and fertilizers even though
sanctions imposed by western nations do
not apply to those products he added
that the u.n broker deal that allowed
ukraine to resume grain exports last
month also included a clause to permit
moscow to ship food and fertilizers to
global markets
new video out of russian-controlled
crimea claims to show the moment
ukrainian drones targeted a military
base in the region video on social media
later showed plumes of smoke rising from
the area russian authorities say a drone
was shot down above the base it's the
latest in a string of attacks near
military bases in russian-held areas of
ukraine and within russian borders kiev
has not taken responsibility for the
latest attack
in somalia's capital at least 20 people
are now dead after a group of islamic
insurgents stormed a hotel
the al-shabab militant group claimed
responsibility for the armed men who
attacked and seized control of the hotel
friday night they also detonated two car
bombs just before the attack today
authorities were still fighting with the
gunman who were holding an unknown
number of hostages inside al-shabaab an
affiliate of al-qaeda has long fought
the somali government aiming to topple
it with its own regime
as a summer of flight delays lost
luggage and cancellations continues to
drag on officials in the u.s have
offered an ultimatum to airlines improve
your customer service policies or the
government will take action as jennifer
johnson reports washington says it's
ready to adopt new regulations if
companies don't step up to support
stranded and delayed travelers
from january till july of this year over
120 000 u.s flights have been canceled
millions more have been delayed and
travelers are fed up i really feel sorry
for everybody that's traveling right now
definitely challenging to fly right now
now the nation's airlines have been
given an ultimatum from the u.s
transportation department improve
customer service or the government will
impose new passenger rights one proposal
could go into effect by the end of the
year the most pressing one is the one
issued as a proposed rule by the u.s
department of transportation which
requires airlines to refund money if
they just delay your flight by more than
three hours or if they change your
arrival or departure city that's a big
departure from previous rules the
transportation secretary has sent a
letter to all the airlines saying the
level of disruption americans have
experienced this summer is unacceptable
american taxpayers paid billions to help
the airlines stay afloat during the
pandemic now government officials want
airlines to spell out their policies
before passengers buy a ticket the
message to the airlines is that you've
got to make it easier for passengers to
understand their rights and you've got
to support passengers when they
experience delays that includes paying
for a hotel if a passenger has to wait
overnight the airlines blame turbulent
summer weather and air traffic control
issues for the bulk of the problems but
most experts say the airlines are still
booking millions of flights without
enough pilots to fly them the airlines
continue to be understaffed they
continue to be over scheduled
the airlines may be motivated to act
quickly a bill in congress has just been
introduced that would require airlines
to issue an immediate refund if they
cancel a flight for any reason with
labor day weekend thanksgiving and
christmas coming up changes can come
soon enough for frustrated travelers
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up the celebrity candidates
putting the price of fame at the
forefront of the upcoming u.s midterm
elections
the u.s is a little more than two months
away from crucial midterm elections
where democrats fear big losses in
congress to pro-trump republicans over
president biden's flailing approval but
a recent shift has suddenly left
republicans worried they may not gain
anything at all as jackson proskow
explains trump's push for erratic
untested and unqualified candidates in
key races might already be backfiring
with voters
it's a good day to vote
it is from a former tv doctor to a
one-time nfl star you know i'm not
coming to the senate to look good i'm
not coming to try to get to become
famous i'm already there republicans are
pinning their hopes of retaking congress
on celebrity candidates endorsed by
former president donald trump we have so
many races that we're leading by a lot
less than three months out from election
day those star candidates are faltering
consumed by low poll numbers scandals
and big gaffes guys that's twenty
dollars for kurute this doesn't include
the tequila i mean that's outrageous
men at oz has struggled to appear
relatable in the pennsylvania senate
race between revelations the former tv
doctor owns 10 houses and the fact that
he actually lives in new jersey
in the arizona governor's race trump
backed carrie lake who backs his
election fraud lies she's well behind
her democratic rival in the polls we're
the fork in the rules people while in
georgia former running back herschel
walker is plagued by accusations of
domestic abuse he had the gun to my
temple
and said
he's going to blow my brains out this
week the top republican in the senate
admitted things don't look good
there's a probably a greater likelihood
to house flips
than the senate
senate races are just different they're
statewide
candidate quality has a lot to do with
the outcome
there's not much the party can do when
its de facto leader still holds such
sway to win trump's endorsement the
candidates have to back the lie that the
2020 election was stolen if you put up
such extreme unqualified candidates
they're both looking like they're on a
path to lose and so i think that's had a
big impact on the outlook for you know
how the november midterm elections will
shake out in a year when democrats once
seemed doomed to defeat over inflation
and joe biden's unpopularity they found
new political life in the choices made
by their rivals jackson proskow global
news washington
ahead quiet quitting trending what the
workplace trend sweeping social media
actually means
you're watching global national
one of the world's biggest social media
platforms might be helping the rise of a
labor movement it's called quiet
quitting a new trend on tick tock
encouraging more employees to rethink
their attitudes and put mental health
above extra work as kyle benning
explains this idea was already picking
up steam outside the app and it could
shift the power balance between
companies and their staff
it's time to shut off it's time to shut
off it's a phenomenon that has taken
tick-tock by storm the idea of working
40 hours a week sounds pretty reasonable
but that isn't always what employers
expect and quiet quitting is a concept
many are considering you're not outright
quitting your job but you're quitting
the idea of going above and beyond
you're still performing your duties but
you're no longer subscribing to the
hustle culture mentality that work has
to be your life experts say it's
something that came forward a few years
ago but working from home has become a
catalyst for how employees view their
work-life balance we have started to
question the way in which we do work we
have started to really we evaluate our
values our lives our work habits and
suddenly this has become front and
center and that balance is something
canadians are contending with an ipsos
poll done for global news in december
2021 found 4 in 10 would rather earn 20
percent less if their work schedule was
limited by the same amount but those
discussions can be tricky to have in the
workplace what employees gonna tell
their boss i'm too stressed i need help
finding balance not enough which is
ultimately what drove to the movement
for quiet quitting and now with
businesses pushing to hire and retain
staff the concept of quiet quitting
could cause a shift in the employer
employee relationship i think that this
is an opportunity for companies to
really reassess what does the office
structure mean what does productivity
mean do we care if people work eight
hours a day if they're getting the job
done the way it is portrayed is still a
question mark for some mathias spitz
mueller from queens university says the
way work is viewed in north america is
far different compared to some
continental european countries so
calling it quitting might be viewed as a
little harsh those are not employees who
are quitting
those are employees who define their
work and their lives in a way that
allows them to bring the very best
version of themselves to work every day
kyle benning global news
next carving a new path how inmates in
bc are finding new purpose through first
nations art
the stanley cup got a warm welcome in
the streets of downtown halifax filled
with crowds of hockey fans as nhl player
nathan mckinnon brought it home for a
special parade celebrating his victory
the nova scotian won his first stanley
cup championship back in june helping
the colorado avalanche triumph over the
tampa bay lightning in the finals it was
the team's first cup win in more than 20
years
behind the walls of a correctional
facility on vancouver island dozens of
inmates are taking part in a large-scale
carving project their goal is a 41-foot
totem pole as kylie stanton reports from
victoria the men are learning new skills
while creating a sense of community
with every move the wood is transformed
a slow methodical process that brings it
back to life running of the lift taking
our time but time is something these men
have on their side you think about it
we're here for because we did something
wrong or something traumatizing happened
to us you know it helps you get through
your days and stuff here we're all
trying to rehabilitate for a handful of
inmates at the vancouver island regional
correctional center this 340 year old
cedar log has provided a sense of
purpose once you get the hang of it it
just comes naturally under the guidance
of artist tom the fortune they've spent
months creating the 41-foot totem a
symbol of strength healing community and
family we're all human but it seems to
be forgotten because they're here
so we want to bring that out in them too
to let them know that you know that's
remembered
out here in the yard away from cells and
structure there are no numbers there are
no ranks
everybody is on a first name basis
everybody's on the same level it sort of
equalized that power dynamic
and
the there's far more comfort back here
it's been
humbling to say the least
the land happens to be traditional
hunting and gathering territory a
crossroads for the region's first
nations but that has never been formally
acknowledged i couldn't think of a
better way to do that than to have a
house poll here at the center
when complete likely by the end of the
summer the pole will be raised into
place in the facility's outdoor exercise
yard what could set a precedent
throughout the province these are the
kinds of
programs and initiatives
that that we are you know as a
government obviously want to to support
and want to to see happen this is
putting corrections back in corrections
they say the cedar is medicine with the
ability to heal and it seems while
working with it the inmates are also
carving out a new path forward for
themselves you come out here and you
kind of lose yourself into carving
you know it's a good way to clear your
head it's good for your soul kathy
stanton global news victoria
quite the program and that is global
national for this saturday night i'm
nitu garcia tonight's your canada is the
totem poles at stanley park in vancouver
we love seeing your canada please keep
emailing your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope you can join us
again tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
[Music]
you